عبر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عن سعادته
همم بعد ابلاغه طبعا بالنتيجه مباراه
المنتخب بين الامريكي والايراني والاتحاد
بفوز المنتخب الامريكي بهدف طبعا بايضا من
جهتها اثر على العوده الى المنصه في حماسه
زائده صارخا في الحشد الولايات المتحده
هدف وايران صفر طبعا تعليقا على اقصاء
المنتخب الامريكي لنظيره الايراني من
تصفيات كاس العالم في الدوحه قال بايضا ان
المنتخب الامريكي انتصر في مباراه لكره
القدم مع ايران مؤكدا انه اتصل بالمدرب
وايضا باللاعبين قبل المباراه لتقديم
الدعم لهم طبعا هذا بالنسبه لرد فعل
الولايات المتحده على لسان الرئيس
الامريكي اما في الداخل الايراني فقط
اطلقت الالعاب الناريه اطلقت الهدفات التي
صاحبها خروج الالاف من المحتاجين في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه طبعا للاحتفال بخساره
منتخب بلادهم امام نظيره الامريكيه ضمن
منافسات كاس العالم
المراقبون يرون ان فالايرانيين بخساره
منتخب بلادهم امام العدو اللدود لطهران
يكشف عن حجم الفجوه بين النظام والجماهير
الايراني هذه الفجوه ادت الى تعرض المنتخب
الايراني لضغوط حكوميه وشعبيه على حد سواء
اثر الاحتجاجات كما وقرر بعض الايرانيين
تشجيع خصومهم طبعا وفقا للمراقبين فان
الكثير من الايرانيين اعتبروا ان المنتخب
الذي يلعب بكاس العالم هو فريق النظام هو
ليس المنتخب الوطني الايراني معتبرين ان
لاعبي المنتخب لم يبدوا التعاطف الكافي مع
المحتاجين دونه
وننتقل الى منطقه اذن في طهران حيث احتفلت
المنطقه في هزيمه منتخب الايراني امام
المنتخب الامريكي وفقا لهذه الصور
المتداوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]